beautiful as ever how did you get into
uh
lucid dreams
how does that whole thing work i don't
know how i got into lucid dreams
i think i just read something online
that talked about conscious dreaming
just the the concept of being awake in
your dreams and i was a teenager at the
time like i'd never even
like i i've dreamed my whole life like
and from a very young age i was writing
down my dreams because they were just so
crazy out of going crazy adventures and
somebody told me when i was really young
that if i write down all my dreams and i
fill up a journal i'll have a really
cool book of all my dreams someday and i
was like oh that sounds cool so
i would do that and then i i became
aware of the concept or the perspective
of being awake while dreaming and it
just completely blew my mind i was like
what you can like be
conscious well
while being asleep
and uh it just like
i don't know just kind of like shook me
in a weird way and i started researching
it more and i started looking into
performing reality checks which is where
you ask yourself if you're dreaming when
you're not dreaming so like right now
i'd be like am i dreaming
i don't think so one of the another good
thing to do is to like ask yourself how
you got here because typically in a
dream you don't remember arriving there
you're kind of just like thrown into a
situation
so i do that and i would do that like
several times a day i would even take a
sharpie and put like a mark on my hand
and every time i saw the mark i would
do a reality check or like set alarms on
my phone and like
several times a day just question
reality just contemplate if anything
looks weird and when you're dreaming if
you ask yourself if you're dreaming or
if you ask yourself how you got
somewhere or if it seems weird it'll
just be different like how did i get
here like i have no [ __ ] idea how i
got here and that's like kind of a
trigger like
did you realize i just questioned
reality enough and then i would while i
was sleeping i would ask myself if i was
dreaming i'd realize i was dreaming i
get really excited and the first time
that i ever became lucid i got so
excited that i just like watched the
dream just like deteriorate like the
floor of the dream fell out and i just
like woke up in my bed and i was like
whoa and i learned online that you have
to learn to stay calm and stay focused
because if you get too excited you're
just gonna wake yourself up
and i just started exploring
going deeper and deeper into
what was possible in my dreams and i i
created like a bucket list for dreaming
there's like things that i wanted to do
and there's things that i still want to
do
and one of the things was i wanted to
be able to make objects change with my
hands or with my thoughts and i was
in a dream i still vividly vividly
remember this
and a car was driving by and i knew i
was dreaming and i was like
and i went like that and the car flipped
and like crashed and explained it was so
loud and it was so gnarly and it was
like
i don't know when you're dreaming and
you're lucid dreaming like you're
actually there like there's nothing that
it's not as any different than what
we're doing right now except for the
only limits in your dreams or the limits
that you create in your head so one of
the other big goals that i had was to
fly i really wanted to fly in my dream
but like
if i stand up right now and i try to fly
off the ground it's not going to work
and i will never be able to convince
myself that it's possible because it's
not but like if you while you're
dreaming can just take something that's
impossible and know that it's possible
if you can convince yourself that you
can fly in your dream it it's weird half
the time i can and half the time i can't
like half the time i'll like be light
and i'll feel like less weight but like
i'll jump and i'll like kind of like
moon jump like i won't actually fly but
like there's just some times where i
just have like the free perspective
that like i can just see myself floating
and i just feel weightless like it's a
hard perspective to acquire to allow
yourself to be okay with like yourself
flying like it's just
it's like because it's not something
people think about that
yeah you don't like like i can't fly
like people don't fly like if you can
like
if you can purely see it in your head
and you can see yourself flying when
you're dreaming
just start flying and i would just fly
around and just like it's the most free
like craziest feeling ever but you know
it's cooler than flying is breathing
underwater
that is the craziest lucid dreaming
experience i've ever had in my entire
life is knowing that
i'm dreaming
and swimming underwater and knowing that
you can't drown surfing i can't drive
yeah exactly i've made waves come out of
the ocean i've surfed the biggest waves
that i've ever seen while lucid i'll get
into more stuff that i've done in my
dreams that kind of relate back to
reality in a second but
god it's just it's it's absolutely
mind-blowing so is it like you when
you're awake you make it a habit of
asking yourself if you're dreaming so
that becomes such contemplate dream
perspectives like what like how you
just have to see yourself lucid dreaming
you have to see yourself in a dream
consciously aware that you're dreaming
you have to create that perspective in
your head like i am a firm believer that
like us as humans like
our minds are capable of things that
like people can't even comprehend like i
think that like everyone's like kind of
connected and like oh you can feel
people's energy like it's like when you
know what somebody's going to say before
they say it's just like an intuitive
thing
oh man
just the whole topic i kind of have been
off of it for a little while but i still
dream all like every single night i have
crazy dreams most of the time they're
just dreams that i like thoroughly enjoy
uh
i haven't been lucid as much lately but
one of the ways that i have been
becoming lucid is by having nightmares
because if something terrible is
happening in a dream like super terrible
i can't i question reality and i realize
when something like if somebody's
holding a gun or like you have just
crazy nightmares you know people have
nightmares always go lucid because i
always realize that it's a dream i've
actually had dreams where people are
chasing me with guns
it's like the scariest situation you
could ever imagine because you're about
to die or so you think
and um
it's like wait this is a dream this
isn't actually happening turn around guy
with the gun
take the gun from him he goes here you
go it's your dream now i just start
flying start doing whatever i want but
what's crazy about dreams is it's really
hard to take information from
like reality into the dream world most
of the time like dreams are emotions and
perspectives and situations you know
like a dream doesn't have to be a place
and it doesn't have to be a conversation
it can be a feeling you know like you
have dreams that are scary you have
dreams that are like about love you have
dreams that are happiness you have
dreams that are like about fear like
there's
there's
a whole bunch of different
types
of like dreams like i said it doesn't
have to be a place or a conversation it
can be just like strictly a feeling
and
it can almost always be equated to
something that happened to you in real
life like
i've had dreams where
like there was a dream uh
i was at gas bro and some lady like
fell off the side of one of the
drawbridges she was like trying to climb
down and she fell and like we had all
these people like helping lift her up
and then like a couple
it was either the next night or a couple
nights later i like had another dream
that it was like a similar situation
where i was like helping somebody like
out of
some like place but
when i thought about
at gasparilla and when i thought about
it and the dream it was like the same
exact situation so like you ever hear
somebody say sleep on it
it's like yeah well if you don't if you
haven't made your mind up on this you
should probably just sleep on it because
your brain goes through everything that
happened the day before while you're
asleep your mind is subconsciously
processing every conversation every
interaction everything that happened to
you that day so like if you surf all day
you're probably going to have dreams
about surfing if you
golf all day you'll probably get better
than i've ever slept in my life yeah
yeah sometimes when you get too
exhausted too you won't have as vivid of
dreams because you're like so deep and
you're subconscious but oh man i could
talk about dreaming forever that's one
of the most fascinating things ever but
like i was talking about breathing
underwater like
i was there's like this bridge right and
on each side of the bridge there's like
crystal clear like streams and it's
almost like it's like a
a giant like concrete structure but it's
like indoor and outdoor it's not like
i'm inside of a place it's like i'm
inside of like a
old structure on the side of a river
like in a jungle somewhere and there's
these crystal clear streams and there's
all these underwater caves and like all
the caves are like well lit and like
when you swim down in a cave it opens up
to this giant room and there's all these
fish and everything and i'm lucid and i
jump in the water and i like you know
you get that tightness feeling in your
chest i was just like this is a dream i
like there's nothing that can hurt me
here i can swim underwater and i should
be able to be relieved like because i've
had dreams where i'm breathing
underwater but
i just feel
myself breathing in my bed it's like not
like i'm actually breathing in the dream
i can feel like myself laying in my bed
and i feel myself like breathing in
reality but like i'm holding my breath
in the dream but i'm still like feeling
my chest being relieved
and uh then there's other lucid dreams
where i'm in the water and i know that
i'm dreaming and i
open my mouth and i like breathe in
water and i feel like the cold water
fill up my lungs and it relieves me like
i don't choke like i feel relieved and
i'm just like
like breathing in this it's like it like
goes from being like
heavy thick water to like it feels like
cold air almost you know but like
perspectives in your dreams can shift so
quickly because like it is an imprint of
your subconscious mind it's not actually
like a real place like
it what's crazy about lucid dreaming is
you have to maintain your focus on the
fact that you're lucid or else you'll
get distracted and you'll snap back into
a dream like i never
ever remember a lucid dream ending i
just continue dreaming you know unless i
wake up but like it's oh man it's
interesting it's like it's so sick it's
so gnarly like i think it's something
everyone should take some time and learn
about because it has absolutely changed
my life like in a small way would be
i was lucid at irb skate park in my
dream i knew that it was a dream and i'm
at the skate park and
i
suck at going front side on the rail
like i had never done front side 50
5050s before
i was like oh i'm dreaming like i can't
get hurt drop in grind across the whole
thing do it a couple times start skating
start shredding and i woke up and i was
like damn like that was so easy went
straight to the skate park dropped in 50
50 grind frontside first try never done
it before besides in my dream but the
dream gave me the confidence that i
needed and the perspective to where like
i went in person and did it
like
unimaginably better than the than i
would have if i didn't have that dream
like it wasn't even a question that the
dream helped me like the dream is the
reason why i landed that trick and
there's a lot
all of the most
like the smartest minds like like nikola
tesla and albert einstein and neil
degrasse tyson like they're all lucid
dreamers they all talk really do they
really
yeah look up like albert einstein look
up uh look up famous lucid dreamers on
google maybe okay it'll be a list of
people that might pop up yeah first one
is like tim dillon and alex jones
bill clinton oh crazy oh man salvador
dali yeah
christopher nolan leonardo dicaprio
stephen king
leonardo dicaprio
i'm telling you a lot of that sounds
good just like that inception deception
is about lucy that's what it is
it's the same way and after you have
this conversation like re-watch that
movie and think about it being loose
it's like a
stephen king i can't i gotta discredit
him because he wrote his best books
while he was doing mountains of cocaine
at the same time
why would that discredit him
[Laughter]
you